well I just think you see more of the
demise of our friendship honestly and I
got so upset that I think it was crying
I was crying cuz I'm just like this is
like the most exciting day like we
finally got engaged like and to receive
a text like that to be reminded it's
like can you wait a few days can you
wait a few days to just like remind me
that I have drama going on how is
quarantine in the new house well thank
God we're in the new house like if we
were still like in ER our perspective
apartments because you lived a block
away I didn't know that we never
actually see each other no I think you
would just be in yours and I'd be in
mine because I being on top of each
other and next small space I don't know
more for sex and maybe like dinner but
what I've isolated separately if not for
that yeah yeah yeah thank God you know
what you know to everyone living with
other people in apartments right now my
hat's off to them like I thank you for
that but you haven't killed each other
yet so that's a good sign
well the engagement episode is finally
here have you gotten to see it yet
you watched it yesterday and we cried
what that is senator what is that saucy
you cried you didn't get choked up you
cried I mean I wasn't falling but I
definitely had water coming out of my
eyes I don't know if I think it was it
was the fact because it was so beautiful
and then it's also the fact that we were
outside there's just yeah there was a
lot of feelings not just the engagements
I'm socializing I miss graveyard
yeah wearing pants sassy
did you really have no idea that
engagement was coming the proposal was
coming right I don't think you
understand and I don't think they like
showed properly this whole season how
like he we got into so many arguments
and there were so many sad moments
because he convinced me that he wasn't
ready anymore and I have been told like
we had been talking like for a full year
about like how he can't wait to marry me
and all these things and you know would
be engaged soon and then he all the
sudden just like remake on that and I
was like yeah I was lying so I was like
you know I'm work has been really slow I
might lose my job
I just want no one yeah so yes very much
yeah yeah you almost dug your own grave
there no pun intended where you decided
to propose which is kind of the perfect
Stassi place to propose yes and then you
get to go have an unprecedented the Lisa
Vanderpump
luncheon yeah obviously one person was
not at that event which I'm sure sparks
an new spiral in the snowball of the
drama with the witches of WeHo where
does that go from here in these last
couple episodes we're gonna see well I
just think you see more of the demise of
our friendship are you okay from like
yesterday and stuff No
and then I started crying and then they
called Carter you know he texted but I
have it on my phone don't forget to
thank Kristen for hooking you guys up
she made it happen and now you and
Stassi treat her like that's some cold
blood right there I'm just like this is
like the most exciting day like we
finally got engaged like and to receive
a text like that to be reminded it's
like can you wait a few days can you
wait a few days to just like remind me
that I have drama going on like why did
you text me that like what have I done
like get out of here bro it was dad it
was 14 that's what I mean and it's like
really now you're gonna know you're
gonna come out and like try to be like
something like knight in shining armor
I'm still so pissed off every time I
think about it and then we seen it again
having those feelings come back was I
can I feel the hip through the computer
for that energy wow that kind of was
that kind of the nail in the coffin
there of like this taking a turn but it
you guys just setting that takes you
kind of I mean that was the nail in the
coffin for Carter yeah that was when
people would try to say stuff on on
Vanderpump I would always like never say
anything cuz he's part of like a group
of friends and I'm involved and he
wasn't really I'm not gonna they're not
gonna talk to the minute he said that I
had to do my interviews I'm like all old
like whatever you want I'm like here's
my feelings this is how I feel this crap
like I'm just wired up just thinking
about I feel like because the show has
expanded into 20 cast members or
whatever we haven't gotten to live in
that like the devolution of that
friendship as much as me maybe you have
what out in past seasons is there
anything that didn't make it to air or
that viewers I'll start getting that's
not clicking for them that you want to
clear off
it's funny I just did a podcast about
this with Katy
I had Katy on my podcast and we talked
about this as respectfully as we
possibly could
it's just it's just that everything is
just like very upsetting now in
hindsight and it is it all sucked we all
you know what where we all went wrong is
that I didn't explain to her like when
you asked us to be honest on camera
about your relationship and then you
made us look like [ __ ] and you
double down on it again at the Reunion
I had a shift instead I backed away on
my regard saying this but Kristen just
got really good at just playing a victim
here it's such a situation and it didn't
start this year it started season 7 like
this started I remember before we
started filming Kristen had said I want
to be more honest about my relationship
I just don't know how to do that and
like we sat with her over and over again
being like okay well like we'll bring it
up like we'll help you bring this to
light you don't have to pretend you're
in this amazing relationship like our
jobs on reality TV are to be honest and
the second that we did that on season 7
she would turn it around on us when the
cameras worth it there and make it look
like we were fools for bringing it up or
bad friends and then that just became
the whole narrative and then the reunion
happened and I expected her to be like
hey really sorry for doing that and she
doubled down on it I just want to be
happy she said I just want to be happy I
wanted to be nice to me I'm looking at I
had the but that's I said my love but
I'm doing it without either of you doing
it on me you know oh you're not pissed
that you're in a relationship I've been
there we've all been there I'm just
think like you just made me look awful
and like friends and now I just want to
back off from you so then it's like that
snowball into just so much more you know
you have like one issue with someone it
just grows and grows and then it got to
the point where like she could have been
a chi gong and i would have been like I
can't behind a deal right
no we're not we have not been sister s
for a while I don't know you anymore
Thanks
that's how it really happened it's not
really about her being a relationship I
mean we've all been there so it seems at
this point there are some fractures in
kind of the og group that can't be
repaired like we've gotten to the place
where people have grown enough apart
that it's not always going to be this
core group of people we once knew to
hang out all the time where do you think
the group kind of goes from here I'm
fine to like say hello ask how her life
is and all of that it's just I don't
know that like I want her so close to me
you know and we've all been through a
lot of friendship breakups before like
this isn't the first time that this kind
of has gone down from talking to
everybody this season though they said
this one felt different well it felt
more smack you know but just because you
don't want someone to be extra close to
you it doesn't mean that you can't be in
the same room together you know how sick
are you of answering questions about
what's up with the wedding okay no it's
okay cuz I love to [ __ ] and moan and
complain like thank you for giving me
the opportunity to do that getting good
um we don't know so we talked to our
wedding planners and they're like we
think you should postpone and I'm like
we're not ready to do that yet so we're
holding off you're gonna hold up to like
the last customer wants to buy tickets
to come they can do it it's just five of
us in Italy like if you need to social
distance to her I don't I don't know we
it's you know we've cried about it we've
also
about it we digested it we've come to
peace with it that it might not happen
and you know I get it it's happening to
so many people and there are much
greater things going on in the world
than like your wedding not being able to
work out but we don't know right now
we're in wedding limbo
what is the quarantine routine like how
many Aperol spritz is are we drinking a
day how many episodes of housewives are
we watching all our traffic I mean okay
the first three weeks of this I was a
monster when it came to drinking and
watching roadies like I could not be
productive to save my life like I didn't
understand I got go on Instagram I see
everyone working out eating healthy
being boss [ __ ] and I'm like sit down
get off my Instagram I'm gonna mute you
you're making me feel bad about myself
but now I kind of have like a rule we're
trying to make a rule where it's like
I've been getting up and working on the
house and stay one so I have like it's
fine in this have all these all these
like projects and things to do I made
like a little home gym outside in the
garage it's like our and two weeks I
know it's there that's all that matters
my biggest question is how did you move
into a house without an OOTD mirror okay
I gave away my other one because it was
IKEA so I'm like no IKEA stuff in the
new mom I'd rather the home be Eric okay
it's time to work on like some adult
[ __ ] and then I didn't realize it until
we were supposed to be like taking
photos for something to send to
something I'm like I don't have a fully
here there's I have not seen myself
full-length in almost two months now but
I think my mirror I ordered one is
supposed to come in two
so good news but right now we need is
the link you just need to see from like
your waist up because that's all
everyone else to see it anyways you know
who you're marrying though yeah great
there you go
where's the pants and the snakes all
right anything else you want Vanderpump
viewers to know before I let you go
about the proposal episode or what still
to come in the last couple episodes I
will say this because we just watched
the rest of the season and the last four
episodes are my favorite of the whole
season I really truly enjoyed them so I
was like oh okay it's like the new
people are like integrated with us
there's a ton more drama than like I
remember like Jax going crazy like just
different people going kind of a [ __ ]
and it's like this is this is good I was
thoroughly entertained so we ended
strong I'm excited to hear that I think
you're like as we've got into the second
half of the season was like oh they
course-correct it a little bit like
we're spending more time with the people
we know I think I feel like the last
four episodes like that yeah yeah but
then they also blend a lot of like good
blend of the new people like it's
organic you know what you guys have to
look forward to I think is really great
television and then whatever reunion we
get we'll get yep I need to start spray
tanning now
[Music]